hey what's going on rich um thank you
for your time and i will keep it brief
so uh since we've last talked um i've
read uh
rolo's second book preventative medicine
which is [ __ ] mind-blowing
and also um re-reading your book for the
fourth time
that being said i am practicing spinning
plates and i went
i was i'm house sitting for a friend's
place getting to the point i met this
girl she was hot
she was on the lawn i like i got her
information and that way i set up a date
on the spot
and she kind of alluded to wanting to
put me in the friend zone but on the
date
she was very touchy with me there were
indicators of interest playing with her
hair
went to several places at the end of the
date there was touching
right like i was in her space and then i
went to kiss her and she's like no i
don't want to do that
but then she said i'd like to hang out
with you again
am i being am i being put in the beta or
is she saying
the medium is the message dude yeah the
medium is a message i mean
if if you look like gigachad thundercock
she would
she would have jumped your bones on the
first date if you made a move right
sure women that start making you know
rules for men and
you know i like you i'd like to see you
again sort of thing i'm not ready for
that you know i have an eight rule date
um i have a bit in my book about the
girl with the eight rule date
who who 50 minutes into the uh date you
know in a few steps in the drink was
telling me
she doesn't bang anybody until eight
dates and then 15 minutes into it after
talking where she wanted to take me to
the bathroom so i could have my way with
her
right so you got to understand that
you've got to pay attention to the
medium
right yeah they're going to [ __ ] test
you and if you're not down with it then
you just have to be firm be like hey
look you already got plenty of friends
i'm not looking for any more i dig your
vibe you know if you want to hang on
again i want you to come over
you know we're going to do this and the
other thing right you kind of work up to
you know the
escalation you should you should
definitely always early on
or as early on express your uh sexual
interest in a woman
um alan roger curry has a great book
called mode one it's
a link to my amazon bookstore have you
read it
no i'd like to i've heard you reference
that
several times he's he's basically
talking about how you don't like dance
around the subject like if you have a
genuine
interest in her and you want to be
intimate with her let her know
right it's not something that you want
to leave you know to the sixth or
seventh date
or you know it comes out as a surprise
at some point so you can start to
express
interest in what you're looking from her
early on but that's a good read too if
you want to check that one out
yeah and i will say real quick rich when
i approached her and we were chatting i
did let her know that you know i thought
she was smoking hot and i said it with
you know as centered as i could have
been and on the day and that's the
reason why i'm bringing it up only
because there was touching and there was
back and forth like i had my hands on
her waist and
we were talking about a lot of different
topics and we went to two different
levels
don't don't overly communicate your
level of attraction in a check very
early on right
i see i see okay like you want to hold
that back a bit that's that's like one
of the things that
you know after you've been seeing her
for a while
and you know you see her walking away
from the bed wearing nothing shaking her
hips in that way that you like
that's that's kind of after you know
that that's like when you whisper those
thoughts after she's like you know
falling head over heels for you sort of
thing she'll do anything
for you you know she makes your bed in
the morning before she leaves you know
all that good stuff right
that's when you drop stuff like that
okay so then the question is and
uh what do you do to make sure you don't
that you know like you you just talked
about you're referring to
that book i'm guessing clarifies this on
a deeper level
but what would you what would you do in
that particular case would you just say
listen i'm not interested in being
friends
basically yeah i've already got lots of
friends um you know if that's what
you're looking for then that's cool
you know you know i'm busy on thursday
night you know i got something else
going on
that's it oh you know let her
let the hamster caffeinated in her head
you know if she wants to come back to
your assistant well
you know hold on a second evan you know
i you know i still want to see him
definitely interesting well
we're going to be escalating next time
you're coming over and you're going to
wear that little black dress that i saw
you in that picture
yeah so that's that and there you go
that's a strong frame yeah
and you for you know you flip it around
that's strong frame now she might
protest she might say no she might say
you know
that's not how she sees you all right
cool strap her off and you know be on
your way
this is next you know that's that's what
a that's what a high value man's going
to do because he's got options
[Music]
and uh yeah okay and i guess i was just
under the thinking of like let me play
the game here because it's like
you know i'm getting on the date i'm
getting some some positive
feedback and i'm thinking oh is it a no
not yet
but i see what you're saying i guess
you're trying to push me correctly if
i'm wrong
to the mindset of don't waste your time
if if it's not
if you can't you cannot negotiate
genuine burning desire
uh moff just dropped in their genuine
desire my friend you can't negotiate it
right
you know it's either there or it's not
there i mean there's things that you can
do to
uh signal higher value when you're
dating you know
when you're communicating like there's
things that you can do which will
caffeinate the hamster in her brain i
talk about some of those things in my
book roller covers in his as well
um you know from a deeper angle from
some different angles as well too but
yeah like
but at the end of the day you can't
negotiate her having genuine burning
desire for you like you want her to be
like that's when you get the best sex of
your lifetime when a chick has genuine
burning desire for you
that's when you know she'll do kind
things for you and bring
gifts and you know surprise you with
blah blah blah when she's got genuine
burning desire so
why even bother investing any of your
time resources or effort into
women that have low interest in you a
better use of your time if all you're
finding is women with low interest and
your
and they're trying to friend zone you is
to level yourself up so that you become
higher value
so that you're the one that's more
spoiled for choice right so
um you know my book i talk about guys
taking a accurate assessment of
their own sexual marketplace value and
deciding whether or not it's a good use
of their time to date or
to increase their value like that's one
of the things you've got to consider too
yep
yep okay and i guess for me right thank
you thank you thank you thank you
all right dev see you man
you